par exemple si serveurs dans
bamba et voilà que si on peut pas que
les gens et tout ça veut dire que moi je
dois vous faire vacciner monchy déjà
vaccinées personnellement c'est à dire
que mes collègues doivent se faire
vacciner
c'est à dire je comprends pas trop qu'il
va devoir le faire donc je sais pas
c'est difficile d'obliger les gens à se
faire vacciner un peu un peu comme ça
chacun grotte un peu ce qu'il veut mais
bon si ça peut rassurer un peu tout le
monde pour qu'on puisse sortir en touche
ou pas il fait beau on se penche plutôt
pour
personnellement je crois que c'est une
bonne idée je pense que c'est très bien
de les vacciner mais que le rendre
obligatoire ce n'est pas le bon moyen
je pense qu'il faut surtout surtout
passer par une information ces personnes
vraiment les encourager à le faire parce
que on a récemment rendu tous les
vaccins obligatoires en france est
finalement crime monde a hurlé monde
était très mécontente réclusion
auxquelles finalement si on parle plutôt
de tous les bénéfices qui vont avoir de
serre vacciner pour gwen et aussi pour
la collectivité c'est vraiment un acte
solidaire peut-être que il accepterait
de prendre ce risque entre guillemets
tout va très vite
dessert avec unifiée
moi je suis contre le principe de
l'obligation ça me pose un problème au
niveau des libertés individuelles
en revanche je peux comprendre la
démarche pour protéger la population et
voilà la santé publique et pour cela je
pense qu'il faudrait plus incité
expliqué charb la pédagogie auprès des
gens mais en tout cas voilà passé par
l'obligation ça me dérange un problème
on va être obligé de faire les
adolescents de 12 ans pareillement alors
pour pour les les médecins pourquoi il
se vaccinent pas un
ça fait déjà montré le bon exemple et
après peut-être si on a des médecins qui
nous disent également surtout ne le fait
pas on sait pas ce qu'il peut se passer
d'ici quelques années s'est injecté
aujourd'hui tout va bien mais dans deux
cinq ans ou dix ans que va-t-il se
passer
et qu'est ce qu'on vous injecte
réellement
qu'est-ce qu'on nous injecte moi j'avoue
que j'ai peur pour le futur de nos
enfants
et de nos parents je trouve assez
pertinent le fait que certaines
personnes qui travaillent tous les jours
avec pas mal de personnes il suffit de
voir mais c'est ici à paris sur les
terrasses les gens qui fréquentent les
terrasses il n'y a plus de distanciation
n'y a plus rien plus rien donc ceux qui
servent ces personnes pour leur plus
grand bonheur
pour le dire peut-être qu'ils pensent à
se mettre à l'abri et ne plus reprendre
danger d'attraper que ce soit alors de
rendre obligatoire n'ont par contre de
le proposer fortement oui je pense que
je rende obligatoire ça n'inclurait pas
un sentiment de responsabilité pas sur
d'autres
proposée
quelles pourraient être les bénéfices
pour soi et pour les autres c'est ça qui
est important on a maintenant à les
médias qui permettent d'élargir le champ
de possibilités pour les différents
acteurs qui est bien là facebook
instagram la télé gala publicité et je
pense qu'il faut vraiment axé là-dessus
pour permettre au grand public de savoir
pourquoi ils de fond et surtout de
sentir vraiment responsables et acteurs
dans
un pour la collectivité